our Christmas party was better this year
okay some people are attributing it to
the fact that Ronnie wasn't there I'm
very happy then I'll make sure I'm not
there at the Christmas party ma'amed
asked me to make him a hero and talk to
him in front of his new girlfriend
uh-huh
so I saw him standing at the bar with
the new girlfriend what's her first name
can you get that or no Mary Mary's I
said to Mary and take away all the
awkwardness hey I heard a lot about you
we talked about you on the air all the
time and Matt wants me to make him look
like a hero so I'm gonna talk to you
then okay
you know we to get all the weirdness out
of the way I knew what was going on yeah
and then we had what 20 minutes of
conversation because I stalk did you
time it at all would you how long would
you say it was like 10-15 minutes
probably 20 to me we talked what did we
talk about after what she did for a
living
you were kind of like bragging about
your paintings a little bit to her but I
showed him some of my paint Brett you
know you're such a I'll tell you what
happens
I'm sitting there with him right I'm
trying to make him you know I'm trying
to make it normal
I don't know what is Mary from a hole in
there but I like my med I wanted him to
feel good mm-hmm so I'm talking to her
and she's talking about she has an
artistic type job you know I can't work
so I go I do some painting so I said oh
that'd be nice I'll show her some of my
paintings on my phone look at my
painting I don't give a [ __ ] if Mary
sees my paintings I'm trying to do this
for memento of course you think I'm
bright the way you I wasn't bragging I
don't even think they're that good
no it was like it was like a humble brag
it wasn't a brag at all no of course it
was very it was I'm trying to have a
personal conversation with her I am so
grateful for that you know a band you
like my band Ronnie make the party
sounds like a great Christmas party
house good so I asked my method the day
after the party or two days after the
party I go how did it go he said it went
well but he described the ER talk is
boring kind of boring
you're sitting right next to me when I
was taking these notes no was not boring
at all I was I bragging too much I'll
tell you why you were what you were
bored because I asked your girlfriend
questions you probably haven't even
asked her and you were like answering
for her like he didn't let her have her
space didn't ya and the conversation
wasn't about him that's why he was bored
yeah I hate about her yeah that's
exactly you hit it right on the [ __ ]
head after the excitement of Seema met
walk in with with Mary was over really
the talk of the party wasn't my met and
Mary it was Brent and Kate yeah I heard
your wife I heard Brent's wife was on
fire basically every woman that talked
to Brent's wife was propositioned by her
in some way
I feel like Brent is way into the
swinger lifestyle like to a point where
like that you make it a point no matter
where you guys are you're looking a
swing right here that's kind of her way
of complimenting the women like she's
not going to actually do anything with
women that if they said yes did you guys
get it on with my men and his girlfriend
no and she liked my Mets girlfriend she
was talking to them and they like might
understand the phrase was I want to eat
your [ __ ] wait your wife where does
that happen
it wasn't that slow of a build-up to be
honest what does she say like how does
that happen like what did she go she
says it to you or to both she spends
five minutes talking about what an
[ __ ] I am and I don't deserve her and
how good her body is and like going into
detail and all that stuff and like what
kind of detail give me the detailing
what's bring my body yeah oh like her
titties or curves I want to eat you know
I want to eat her she said you said I
want to eat your vaginal area she said
she said I want to eat your [ __ ] bro I
would eat her [ __ ] right and she was
asking can I make out with her I said
well I really let Mary make those
decisions for herself right I thought
you know that was me just politely being
like no no thank you
so my girlfriend comes up to me and she
says Caitlin told me that you went up to
her and said you want us to make out
together like no no I didn't say that at
all she put words in your mouth yes
exactly yeah did Caitlin tell you that
she was interested that my girlfriend
was interested no because Brent's thing
is this is what I observe
Brent's thing is he sends Caitlin out to
like Tommy's girls yeah and he sits in
the corner like a creep like just
staring at you with these like yeah
we're gonna be [ __ ] cousin's
girlfriend tonight eyes and he's staring
at you or share your girlfriend both of
us like wow I feel like Brant was giving
me a look
yeah brother she's going down this is
going down I'm like no brother it's not
going down right do you recall staring
at memento I was well I was watching and
after a while he had hungry eyes man
he's making this room I'm interpreting
it everyone like in this building was
talking to me about it after what
everybody else see this going down I
mean I saw the whole Brent wife's you
know making the moves around the party
and it doesn't you know she would say to
oh you know a woman like oh I want to
make out like JD's wife yeah before we
left the party like get your wife drunk
next year and we'll make out like
Brent's never around when that's happens
kind of like ok he's doing the stairs
eventually told me that your wife like
wanted to hit him I I don't and you said
katelynn started hitting and kicking him
at the Christmas party she challenged
him to a fight what happened with the
Brent's wife um she came up to me
because some of the wives were upset
about what I did like about the party
it's way too loud and it's very hard to
talk people enjoy the party at Benjie
don't [ __ ] this party up for everyone
else you better get out here you know
it's obligatory a lot of people were
angry with you that you almost killed
the party yeah yeah did you have a good
time or was it 9 a good time it was a
good time yeah it's a blicket Orie it
was obligatory all yes all right and so
what happened with the Kaitlyn oh so she
came so then Kailyn came up to me again
like was upset about the party what I
had said she starts like like really
punching me but like really hard weird
like at the chest everywhere yeah
everywhere my body was face and it was
really hurting I'm trying to laugh to
like right this is but it was like she
was [ __ ] and she was like I think I
really want to fight you I think I could
beat you up Wow she's on fire but it was
embarrassing because I'm yeah
to be fair to Brent's wife you're built
like a punching bag
yeah Shetty hey you know for a long time
I love you guys listen I have been
putting up with and giving an active
benefit of a doubt Paro but what he said
today I think you certifiably insane
the fact that he thinks that you were
bragging about your paintings I'm giving
up on it
well it is weird to me I mean I really I
extended myself just calm down
listen I heard you're offended that the
panel didn't think your girl was the
hottest girl there I just think they're
full of [ __ ] I mean that you know that
your girlfriend was the hottest I feel
like everyone should feel that about
their girlfriend or wife do you think
there might be some guys who really
don't think your girlfriend was the most
beautiful maybe and that's fine I don't
care what if I say she's not the hottest
I know what a horrible horrible thing
I'm doing I think my therapist put it
best good
I always leave I'm hard on myself right
anyone and I'm constantly on a journey
to become a better person right but a
cowboy we've got lots of work to do but
my therapist told me he said you're the
prize I'm the prize I'm terrible yes Wow
are you your own there is your therapist
named Ahmet in other words you're she's
lucky to be with you don't [ __ ] it up
you're an [ __ ] you always say the
wrong you're on the prod right right
right right Fred what's going on here
I'm baffled by him I'm hoping that this
is a gimmick
he's in deep serious [ __ ] no that's why
I'm in therapy therapy is back in thighs
all right well it's good you're back in
therapy I like that I like to hear this
do you think I'm being serious now do
you think this panel of guys here is a
little bit jealous of your relationship
with your girlfriend because she is so
hot
tell the truth what do you think I think
well again so I say yes I say the truth
and now all of a sudden I'm the [ __ ]
but I'm just I don't go around the
office saying oh you guys are jealous of
me that's what people at home don't do
it on air how is the relationship going
since the Christmas party is it
full-force are you going full scream
ahead or there leave or not all kidding
aside it's better than ever yeah I love
her so much
oh I've been heard this she's really
great and that's why I make these steps
to make myself a better person she makes
me want to be a better person yeah well
there you go mimetic congratulations on
having the hottest girl at the party
Courtney thank you all right thank you
you're the prize buddy you're the prize